just out of my own
sort of curiosity whenever people say
sort of grass-fed meat is better for you
are all grass-fed meat made the same is
there a different like
le it's like the word organic is there a
lot of variety within that
like the way belcampa does it with it
others do it just
more color if you could add to this
whole word and what it means
grass-fed beef has been on grass its
entire life and you want to look for the
words 100
grass-fed and or grass-fed and finished
now
the challenge with feeding
beef grass its whole life is that
it gains weight more slowly
although beef didn't evolve eating corn
and things
it can't eat them and in eating them it
gains weight more rapidly
and has like a version of like an
inflammatory response
if you actually look inside the rumen of
the animal inside the stomach it's like
black and shiny inside compared to
grass-fed animals like greens smells
like compost
so the animals themselves their whole
physiology is is damaged by that
food but they also gain weight really
quickly and they put on a lot of fats
like if you or me were to eat
a bunch of processed food compared to
eating a bunch of greens it's the same
impact you're gonna blow up
so the problem for grass-fed is
getting the animals to gain weight
they're getting a ton of exercise
they're eating really clean right and
they're super chill
so that's different from the animals
that are kept still
eating really nutrient dense foods and
under a ton of stress
which is a confinement animal so are all
grass-fed meats created the same
the diet yeah nutritional profile
broadly
but the length of time that the animal
lives is extremely important for
the flavor of the meat we're taking
our beef to 24 to 26 months conventional
is around 18 months
so i'm always looking and if you're
evaluating grass-fed animals you want to
get animals that are typically uh
allowed to live for longer because their
flavor is going to be better there's
going to be a bit more fat
um and their omega ratios
also vary very differently and i've seen
omega ratios you know on our farm
everywhere from one to three to one to
one
you ideal as one to one game is
typically one to one or one to two omega
three to sixes
but in operations where you don't have
year-round grass
it's more complicated you know you're
feeding hay and you don't get that three
to six ratio
omega threes come from green grass um
they they're the fat in greens
and so they're scarce and costly right
so you can have grass-fed and finnish
animals that don't have that perfect
ratio because maybe they're in a climate
or
for whatever reasons we've had to do it
too during the droughts do hay finishing
it's not optimal it changes the ratio
but
so there's a little bit of variance
within it i'd say though
they the variance within grass-fed is
still
small compared to the variance between
conventional and grass-fed
right so there's definitely things to
look for within it but the the real
difference is between those
two also thing to notice is that
it's not a verified word okay so
grass fed means animals that have been
on grass at some point in their life
the way the cattle industry is in the
u.s
there's segmentation so there's
cow calf operations there's then those
calves get sold to stalker operations
which raise
animals in their teens basically and
then those get sold to feedlots
and so those three phases that that
first phase of the cow calf is always on
grass
it's mother cows and mom cows are
amazing they can thrive on
anything and still put all their
nutrients into their baby and their
babies will be healthy
so you never putting weather cows on
really premium pasture
so it's usually just kind of like okay
pasture dirty like if you ever see kind
of like
you know scrubby lots with lots of you
know cows and cavs that's a cow calf
operation
so there's also a worm a loophole
unfortunately where people use the term
grass fed
and they're actually referring to
animals that at some point in their life
had grass but that might be
pretty far in the rearview mirror so you
need to see look at that
uh grass-fed and finished or grass-fed
that ratio of omega-3s to six is it
changes in like a week
on grain wow so it's radically different
unfortunately it's the same thing for
you and me you could eat clean for a
month
you eat you know junk for three days
you're garbage right it's not like you
can just like coast on that
right we know what that's like same
thing for animals our physiology changes
food's the number one way we interact
with our environment
yeah and our body changes really rapidly
and dramatically so
so we know belcampo and just the way
sort of this regenerative farming
approach of belcampo
and the sort of high humane is good for
the land
is good for the animal can you comment
on
ways it's good for the human that eats
the meat
is is this me better for you yes
it's and this is where you know the kind
of focus on the joy
and animals doing yoga and all this sort
of like cynical stuff about
about this type of agriculture say just
like
set that aside you know it really is
better for your health
yeah it's got a better fat ratio it's
less inflammatory
it's got higher protein it's just better
product
i mean in the case of beef it's lower in
fat
and that fat has a better quality and
it's higher in poultry and pork is also
higher in protein so
all the nutritionals are better it's got
higher density of vitamins got higher
density of minerals and none of this
stuff is
radically different than you know it's
not not like it's the product is
is black and white but their every
metric meaningfully is better in the
right direction
across the board so why wouldn't you
you